[Music]
oat milk latte light foam
hey
how's uh lamar's boyfriend long distance
dating sucks how long have you guys been
together eight years eight years how did
you manage that he checks all the boxes
oh you mean literally strong jaw mental
fortitude six-pack
we had a plan and then he got his
martian dream job
so i enrolled in the mars program
you ever worry the wrong person is
headed to the wrong planet goodbye
foreverwalt
five
four
three
two
hello hey
what are you doing here who sneaks onto
spaceships i can explain
ever since i was a kid i dreamt of going
to mars
you can keep my dream alive come with me
you cannot under any circumstances leave
my room okay
this is gonna suck isn't it only for 35
days
you have to keep a low profile
[Music]
all right you guys i'm your captain this
is sophie my girlfriend long-term
girlfriend i don't remember you from
orientation
what happened
did you have to come right back and just
rip his jumpsuit off
[Laughter]
hey what's up i just miss you sorry do
we have a call scheduled
come on let's go have some fun i don't
do fun you also don't fly on rockets
we're conspired with stowaways sophie
for walt disney 100 bucks says you just
said that in your wrist you just gotta
face it you're a space criminal now
historic journey to make life more
meaningful
now that is a story people want to hear
you've spent your entire life trying to
check an impossible set of foxes
i can't risk the plan
can you find that thing that you're
willing to cross the entire universe to
be with
make sure it's ready to do the same for
you
[Music]
it doesn't matter how far you travel
you can never escape yourself did you
just come up with that
no [ __ ] that is a very common phrase
[Music]
[Music]
you